thank you to both rocket money and
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation it
is time for Monarch episode 6 today John
how are you I'm good I'm ready to love
this one G that's what I like to hear
guys what did you think about this
episode if you're watching this video
you've already seen it leave your
thoughts down below how's Monarch been
for you overall ladies and gentlemen you
know what to do go ahead leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe click that notification Bell
to get notifi when our next reaction
from Monarch is up here on this Chanel
thank you to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights and thank you to
all of you who have followed us over at
our patreon page over there you get the
full length ratch and watch along that's
where you sync up with your own copy of
Monarch and also John and I Rec cover
several shows over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included John you ready to get into this
so ready let's do this let's do
it
[Music]
ah yes the past what did I tell you I'm
going to love
this a yes oh my God that Blazer all
these Caucasians
hey they must have banged at one point
AA they do look lovely the both of them
doctor I'm supposed to wear this no no
no no you're supposed to eat it I
thought you might be hungry so I picked
you up some along the way that's racist
is it racist yeah maybe I don't know
okay or is she being sweet I don't know
I'm expected to impress man who can't
remember my name and would just as soon
shut us down as turnu Weaponry why isn't
really here fair just
koperate you're lucky to be here at all
say hello say say thank you to the
people who are footing the bill and now
we can go on our merry way
exhale smile fall in love with me
yes captain Lee Shaw when he was
respected up him out of a a bar brawl
it's all busted up are you drunk yeah
he's alliterating like mad do you
remember what I told you to do to
succeed in this man's Army remember when
we were alone in your office
only punch Sailors and Marines from now
on and the crowd
[Music]
laugh ah you got me Dr K Mira thank you
Captain Europe Japanese name yeah hey
she's one of the good ones
whoa what do you mean whoo you said
she's one of the good ones yeah so and
so is he so is Chris H doll of
course
one of the good ones it's a
compliment you're one of the good women
and one of the good Japanese people guys
like them they are oldfashioned if we
ever find another Titan those
oldfashioned men will blow it up or
March it into Red Square yeah that's the
truth now you're going to change their
minds in as oldfashioned as they may be
no cuz it's what you do you did it to me
you are a force of
nature you haven't seen anything yet you
are the Titan of my
heart everyone is looking at us they're
all thinking the same thing he's dancing
with one of the good Japanese women
yes now do some kind of like big show
stop and swing number get the whole room
looking at you then you'll secure all
the funding and maybe some karate with a
samurai
[Music]
sword and that was the moment he decided
to shun away
Lea
oh that's the best
moment
oh he was attracted to her too I mean
this romance is nothing like kiry
Clemens and
canara yeah can we get back to the real
Beating Heart of the show
please
a that was so lovely you could be one of
them being career military might not be
so bad more nights like this a life like
this you can be controlled even more a
house neighbors Barbecues in the
backyard kids kids bring it back to
episode
one kid oh they they heard
you
oh the pinkies do you know what my
favorite thing about children is never
afraid to say I don't know everything
every day is an adventure and a mystery
that's was pretty know at all child
want don't know what my favorite thing
about children is you can hit them with
a belt making them learn them good I
think they're foreshadowing them having
maybe children urgent message for
captain Lee Shaw from Bill
random oh maybe next L Soldier
oh no freaking Bill Randa he knew what
he was
doing see all just got a approach this
with a beginner's
[Music]
mind they did the secret knock change
your that's
[Music]
clever oh yeah that was cool that was
pretty cool that's pretty
sweet clean
ooh
cleaner my nuts the things I cut for mon
but I got a good idea about what's going
on didn't do enough about that when I
had the chance figure on making up for
that now you're here they've known
everything for years I've been telling
them for years and they keep ignoring
what tell me what tell me why tell us
we'll believe you why not
because I'm crazy just like Wild Bill
Randa and his crazy kid hero how anyone
who disagrees with him is got to be just
crazy crazy Wild
Bill
uh-oh what about you mamelle hand is
shaking doubt the system my sister
Sandra she worked in Japan some of us
came to Monarch saying never again I
meant it oh and there're more who feel
like me waiting for someone to show home
you need to
Blink you won't be crying if you just
you know hydrate your eyes does that
make me crazy I think you and I have a
lot to talk about yeah you guys got a
lot to inform the audience about this is
like that 2014 Godzilla movie except
instead of like only getting fleeting
glimpses of Godzilla it's fleeting
glimpses of any kind of the
answer sorry for interrupting your big
whatever the hell it was I don't give a
[__] but I think we got a live one my
man a guy thinks he saw it but isn't
sure what kind of a data are we
sorry
oh the only other time I've seen
isotopic signatures like this was in the
Philippines uhoh poo
Pride this is a Titan it's not
definitively not a Titan okay that's
definitively not an answer what is it
three most beautiful words in the
English language I don't
know mindset children yes we divide and
conquer you stay and deal with the
hardware storm no no no I'm not letting
you go on a Titan hunt alone well who
can we leave behind or you both of you
either you know what I mean sheepers but
we need to prove Titans exist to get
money for the good of Monarch
something's got to
give oh boy rocking a hard
place Jack Nichols it's in the middle of
the Sahara woo
woohoo Let's go Team how are we even
going to get there get where Mom [__]
Colonel hey what's she doing here well
Michelle's dancing on the side of the
Angels now I don't know we can use her
help something's coming gday * 100 G I
think your father's trying to stop
what's coming and I got a pretty good
idea how he's going to do it only way to
know for sure is to find him m- she
tried kidnapping me what are we talking
about we're going to the hollow Earth on
Monarch's orders but she's not taking
orders from Monarch anymore because
she's with us and you can trust her and
I'm going to say all that for her she's
our ride now all we need is a
destination which is of course where you
come in get your Maps boy I mean the
only other incident that happened would
be the Godzilla versus Comm that
Godzilla I guess Hoshi he he RS the
office with the million dooll view right
but he sits with his back to it why so
he can
stare how whatever was here oh good call
yes like an office you're like Sherlock
Holmes
dude
[Music]
yeah
the mystery
intensifies this pattern it's familiar
right these holes what how would you
really would you really put this her
what did roshi do to get exiled from
Monarch his file sealed he wasn't exiled
misuse of government assets government
Maps he kept retargeting deep space
satellites to look at things they
weren't supposed to like what like Earth
well what do they normally look at space
deep
space far away [__] you know that you
can you know that electromagnetic
spectrum Cosmic radiation gamas oh and
these files
become Monarch these are all places
Monarch has or ever had boots on the
ground you got all that from the holes
there's got to be a reason this guy has
a job at Monarch let him cook I I'll
give him the benefit of the doubt for
now it's leading to answers at least
if we pull the data on where Hiroshi was
redirecting the satellites we will get a
perfect match Godzilla emerges west of
Hawaii at this cluster heads towards the
mainland gamma race bike right oh swims
West another Spike but Hiroshi flew
North to this cluster another gamma race
bike where we found Shaw his kids and
that new Titan
oh so they're looking for their father
dad's boy it looks like Hiroshi recorded
three more Gam surges here in Central
Asia and what would that be Vietnam
Cambodia and here uh-oh I can't get over
the fact he saw very vague holes on that
and was like don't these holes look
familiar well you know he was like
here's a pin and maybe this used to be a
corkboard I'll I I'll give it to him but
I get you I'm teetering on the edge
remarkably fast you know oh my God he's
wearing his classic outfit
hey that eventually he'll fill out yep
it's a very flexible
out is this who I think it is
oh I don't think it
is is it you never
[Music]
know Monster Island whatever out
generate radiation at Cosmic levels so I
constructed that a g radiation simulator
whoa the more signals I simulate the
more radiation whatever is out there
generates in no Sara will be like 100 by
the time yeah but maybe he's got that LE
[__] that that he's got he's 90 doesn't
look
it we're in the right
[Laughter]
place they always look fresh off the
rack this wasn't part of our deal when
do I get to go home the sunglasses I'll
keep my word yeah when as soon as we
make it out of the desert the desert
that we shot this scene
in good seeing you Scotty I don't want
anything to do with an arm Aron X monar
goon all the apples in the Monarch
Barrel aren't bad Kate uh-oh the colonel
is starting a movement we're not here to
start a movement okay it's a trap all
right this is where you want off just
understand understand that consequences
will be on your heads now too what
consequences thousands maybe millions of
lives lost that your grandparents and
father were trying to save that's why he
had two families yes in order to save
more lives if you want to bail we can
bail I wanted to call it a day in Alaska
someone setting that up in pistan hat
the only way out is thr boom skip has
anything they have to
say no we had to call back to a few
episodes ago when they bonded that one
time please skip thanks for your help oh
he knows he knows the dial of
Destiny our
comedies exactly what kind of fish are
we talking about here Billy a big one
wish you were here pal no he loves you
too you know I don't recall receiving
your RSVP for my family cookout Captain
General I request a hot dog with extra
ketchup sir
my people are in the field and they need
me sir no we have men for that lead call
them the Army not the Army sir just me I
see great things in your future Le you
got to sit at the grown-ups table if you
want them it's called building a career
oh Monarch is my career sir then stop
treating it like a job damn there are
generals and there are soldiers I
understand that sir you could have
fooled me now you have a choice to make
and I trust you to make it the 50 scenes
are just so much better it's so much
more simple wholesome I'm sure this is
the spot on the map what that means
exactly only your dad can tell us I
think it's just over this
Ridge let's go come on
[Music]
team I don't know where she's just going
to blur it out I had a gay Affair yes I
feel real guilty about it I'm
sorry you could have just called it an
affair yeah it doesn't matter really the
emotional damage is the
same see
there is that
Dad oh my
god oh and he's got a modified version
of the thing oh man how great would it
be if he just died right before their
eyes right now is just dropped out of a
heart attack
yeah oh no oh I think some's going to
come kill him right now he going die
he's calling
something saying get away yeah he's
waving him
[Music]
off ooh this is
intense
[Laughter]
oh oh [__] go oh wait this is a
flashback they've gone fishing
spooky good shot have you ever seen one
or Saturn a
Titan
yes we have greatest day of my life
great now he's in love other yes
everyone
bars not every Asian actor who's
enthusiastic is heu Kuan John shut up
I'm sorry they're just all key to
me Lee didn't think you were going to
make the party deck him
Lee I'm taking you girl he made a a GMA
radiation simulator that actually
simulates um you know the only thing
worse than being a third wheel being a
fourth let's walk whoa getting that
clearing the way you see like he stopped
caring about the actual Mission and too
much about her she had to push him away
yeah breaks my heart and randa's just
married to his Titans you know I think
he's waving us off what's going on no no
[Music]
no
oh oh no this poor guy maybe he was just
dodging the awkward confrontation
between his two children I don't want
talking about my two families go it's a
weird time in my life
oo oh good oh
good
first an ice Kaiju now a desert kaijou
yeah one for every climate you weren't
supposed to come my place is here with
you you need what love your job is to
protect Monarch without you there is no
Monarch found a good way to justify
spending time with
her nice friend you know we can't do
this we can try how long before I NE of
us makes a decision based on what we
want instead of what mon needs pretty
soon so Bill Randy just got in like at
one point was like you know what I'm
going to dat yeah I
guess we can't put the greater good
before our own desires the great are
good risk losing everything I don't care
I put my desires before all great are
good oh damn she's pregnant let's
go
yes you do
[Music]
oh here come what the device your love
your love attracted to Titan where is it
it's been swallowed what an interesting
lens
oh take it
back oh sh [__] oh it's
Godzilla I had know those dorsal KS
anywhere whoa nice he's
alive
oh
yeah I hope you brought enough for
everyone oh yeah Jesus Christ we didn't
kill
it a she's so happy thank
God oh here we go history is repeating
itself what were you doing out there
hero
oh is it Gods again or is it like rock
Godzilla oh dirt Zilla yeah so we just
like hibernating here yeah I guess so
getting all toasty warming its blood
up
wao wow everyone will survive
this
oh oh no canaro my man
[Music]
dude oh [__] wow right face your trauma
jeez that's scary that is scary waking
up just roll R over in
bed I love
it oh that's
scary the one they've all
feared the
king oh King
Titan yeah what is the pilot doing right
now oh [__]
oh
no you harm one hair on hell
yeah yeah look at that M cut the
commercial ear
pods and that's the last we see of
Godzilla he saw me yeah he did dude you
got to connection got a psychic Bond he
knows about your gay
Affair and he thinks you should just
call it an affair so we can't keep that
to ourselves so we tell them and then
what they build an even bigger weapon
and try again and if that doesn't work
an even bigger one and if they can't
find Goda maybe then they'll find
somebody else to use it on yeah buddy
well we need to protect
ourselves okay and I certainly wasn't
supposed to come back empty-handed so I
need something I can put in front of
pocket so so we can get our asses out of
the dogghouse how about some eggs I'll
try and go sell this to
Pucket uh-oh you've been infiltrated
just going over some of your field
reports uh what's going on in the Navy
we call it a change of command in the
Navy you can take over an operation I'll
expect a full report and accounting of
your little field trip on my desk my end
of day what you done made the wrong
choice bucko
did you find anyone no one survived the
crash and we're running out of time got
her makeup still looks great yeah man so
we Chase Godzilla then what more people
die we can't stop him Jesus Kate I'm
trying to help him hey if you come with
me you'll know everything I promise you
no thank God the only place we're going
is after our father Kate just go with
him I want to know what the hell he's
been talking about this whole show and
it'll probably lead to your father
anyway civilization is just 10 clicks
that way you go now you'll be there long
before dinner alons
Al Doctor Who fan over here he's
probably seen it through every
iteration yeah he's old
enough that's how he's alive
regeneration maybe he was running from
Godzilla or trying to lure him you know
away from us we know he made it the
farar and so did we he's alive so we
keep looking all right oh I can't do
this anymore oh my god this is my fault
what do you mean seriously no I sold you
out did you a couple of years ago I
pissed some people off until I had to
run and I ran to Japan uh-huh until
Monarch figured me out when they picked
us up and they left the deal on the
table and they said that if I told them
where we were I could go home and I
could get my life back and I could be
with my family a the only way I is
through F I have money I don't want your
godamn money listen I have a lot of
money I can get us wherever you want
want to go go to help well I don't have
that much money Kate I'm
[Music]
sorry but the both of you I whatever
Kate come back come back Kate we Bond it
in Alaska Kate don't don't walk over
there Kate Kate don't Kate you're
walking you know don't walk to the third
click I can see you for Miles
Kate
jeez
you know what I'll say what's that say
it I'll say that with all that money she
has a great way to manage that yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's hear about it would be
with
um some fuel oh yeah into your rocket
ship oh take you into the cosmos of M
I'm transitioning stop talking about gay
Affairs hey reject Nation you know
running real rejects is an incredible
journey something I am truly grateful
for but I got to be real with you for
one second here managing the business
side especially taxes to put it lightly
is incredibly overwhelming it's like
navigating a maze without a map and
that's where our sponsor rocket money
comes in a sponsor when approached I was
so excited to work with because I kid
you not just last month I started using
rocket money cuz I needed to sort out
this financial puzzle and honestly it's
been quite eye openening not just for
taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche
of this app is true I discovered apps
and subscriptions I have been paying for
that I had not used in ages it is like
finding out you've been leaving lights
on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's
like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
if finds and cancels those forgotten
subscriptions monitors your spending and
even battles to lower your bills thank
God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned
money like I try I really try to be on
top of my expenses but rocket money they
show me blind spots with a simple tab I
can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of
negotiating with customer services a
relief my goodness to put it into
perspective rocket money has helped over
5 million users save an average of $720
a year that's more than just numbers
it's a piece of mine so if I invite you
my fellow Rejects and taking control of
your finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's
rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
rocket.com re
I really do stand by this app thank you
for partnering with us as many of you
guys know most of my days are a couple
of hours of filming and then most of the
time it's dedicated to like editing and
a bunch of other computer work often
accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a
day and on top of that comfort food is
like my life's biggest Vice but as many
of you also know working out and getting
healthier has been a massive component
for me this year in particular so in
this Whirlwind I have found myself a
perfect Ally for quick healthy meals
America's number one meal kit a meal kit
that I have subscribed to prior to ever
agreeing and working with them so yes
this is a genuine testimony and that is
of course for hello fresh and hellofresh
isn't just about ease about bringing
health and flavor to your doorstep in
this holiday season forget about the
stress of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hello fresh I'm
looking forward to hosting holiday
dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best
part the variety it is incredible I'm p
V Arian so they have these delicious
meals just like dejon onion crunch
salmon over lemon broccoli spaghetti and
for one more plant-based days the vegan
Maple carrot power bowls they aren't
just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long
day the last thing I want to do is spend
a while cooking and that's where helloof
Fresh's 15minute meals are a lifesaver
they're quick nutritious and Oho tasty
perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday
season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45
recipes and seasonal add-ons to choose
from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer
about go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free
breakfast for life is that accurate that
sounds way too good to be true there's
no way that can be true go to
hellofresh.com reject free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for Life
One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your
hellofresh creations with # hellofresh
pick and at hello fresh and let's cook
up some fun and healthiness reject
Nation remember it's America's number
one meal kit well that was possibly the
best episode they've done so far in my
personal and objective opinion agree
John what did you think I got exactly
what I was hoping for I loved it I loved
it so much no it was all right I liked
it it was good it was the best one so
far it had some things that I tend to
not love love about the show still in
effect however had a lot more balance of
things that made me enjoy both timelines
to varying degrees uh so yeah I I would
say while still not like loving it the
way I maybe want to be this was a much
more positive and fun experience than
some of the previous episodes did Apple
just like run out of money with Godzilla
I'm very fascinated to know if that's
the case whenever I I thought like oh
[__] looks like we're going to get like
a real Godzilla episode all of a sudden
oh he's gone there There He Go we got
this this one good few shots of a sequin
he just he just walked away yeah yeah he
just like walked out he just walked
away disappeared like what did you get
do could keep up with him did you burrow
underneath a mountain already without
any seismic activity this is the run
that we see in Godzilla xcon he learned
how to do it right there he learned how
to do the Batman vanish like [__] god
wow stealthy guy that's why he's the kid
oh don't worry we'll find our dad oh
he's he's just gone just freaking gone
there's no tire tracks he can't see a
distant vanan anywhere of a [__] that
his old friend was back that his
daughter and his son were there didn't
give a [__] about any of that yeah that
felt about in line with how everything
in The Show
Goes get the hell out of here got to
find her dad no get out of here got to
find her dead get leave there's a reason
I want to be around you
guys um but yeah no it the 50 storyline
is of the origins of
Monarch uh is progressively the one most
intriguing element in terms of like an
actual story yeah to me at least agree
the other stuff kind of fluctuates
between interesting to just give me
something to chew on a little bit please
and to oh my God I feel like they
sometimes it just thinks they're telling
us new information take the Columbo
scene we kind of knew all that sure
right like for the most part we just
need to check in it was maybe like one
or two sentences we did not know but for
the most part we knew all that but the
way they reveal it and spend time there
it kind of makes you think wow we got no
we didn't we knew all that yeah because
it only brought us as far as our main
protagonists get yeah then they just
show up to get hit by the Godzilla um
fin yeah and then they disappear so that
he can that Tim can come back next
episode with like a horrific scar on his
face yeah and a darker
tone I am Kobo I'm now Robo I'm Alex
Murphy okay Dr Tim
Doom yeah um disappearing but the stuff
in Monarch in the 50s origin like that
stuff is really tense and taut and and
there's there the even even like the the
RO that that is the star everything they
attempt to do in the present day and
they apply since it is like a mirror
effect in history repeating itself and
then present day resolving things from
the past every type of Mystery Box
intriguing element character-driven
narrative that they try to
do uh which is the reflection in a lot
of ways of the past the past is where
it's all actually intriguing even though
I know Kurt Russell's character does not
end up with this doctor lady I I'm still
like what happened here I want to know
what happened here how did Monarch come
to be how did Lee Shaw go from respected
revered supposed to be the main man in
charge of Monarch the to suddenly
getting pushed down the ranks uh demoted
what like what became of them like I am
actually every time we cut back to them
I want to know what happened even though
we know the outcome does not end in
their favor I really I really am there
going like God let me and I feel like
they Advance the story I feel like we
actually
progress and uh the visuals there I I
think just because of 50s aesthetic they
when you apply a little bit of a Sheen
over some familiar settings it is is
just automatically more intriguing and
more Dynamic right away uh yeah so I I
really love everything they do there and
and the chemistry between the three even
the uh
romantic uh what's it love triangle even
the love triangle uh aspects of it which
is such a Trope in
television uh it's still even here like
how did Randa just get on board with
like yeah I can see that my buddy's kind
of in love with her I'm the Third Wheel
here then eventually he's like I'm marry
you or I'm going to pregnant you or
whatever it happens I forget I forget
what they D I can't tell yeah if he's
just like you they're together in the
first episode when they goow to the
flashback right yeah they're a couple
yeah and they have a kid together yeah
and so part of me I don't know maybe he
is just so much like yeah I really am
just married to my uh my work here and
I'm really just this is what enchants my
life so if you guys are interested in
love you should do that I don't know I
don't know what to think about that um
maybe he Rand falls in love with her
eventually well yeah I guess I don't
know it it they the way not maybe yeah
the way they've played the character
just seems like is not really that it it
on one hand feels like he suspects them
but love but he cares about Lee and and
you know feels like they're friends and
Lee is probably mostly just fixated on
he doesn't suspect them he plat out says
what's worse than being a third wheel a
fourth wheel he knows he's third
Wheeling the situation yeah I guess so
so like I don't know yeah maybe this
maybe what we saw here in this episode
will lead to the rift or I don't know
like it is I am a little question about
like the trajectory and and bullet
points of their dynamic because at the
moment he does just seem like oh yeah
well you guys are really hitting it off
so you do your thing because I'm
interested in this gamma Dinner Bell you
know yeah and and uh well it seems like
what's what's her name good Japanese
woman yes yeah one of the good ones one
of the good ones one of the good ones
Japanese woman uh okay that's what the
show told me to feel about her yes and K
well it seems like K and Shaw they they
couldn't be together like no I mean
their their love seems quite rather
doomed yeah but beyond it's not just
like oh we didn't get along or some [__]
it's because of the positions that they
hold and goals and motivations that
interfere yeah and a whole bunch of
things that that get in the way that
would prevent them from being together
to the things that she's bringing up in
this episode of uh this would cause a
rift between us and there's no way we
can actually make this work yeah so
that's your position and mine are kind
of antithetical yeah so him showing up
is the thing that that's why she's not
like happy to see him when he shows up
yeah of course because he should be
staying behind and doing his part and
then because he went over there it led a
little bit more to their downfall yeah
the love is is kind of directly in
obstacle to Monarch forming the right
way that's what happens to Asian
fetishes man they get in the way that's
right just ask my dad oh boy look out
now
um um but yeah I I I I don't know yeah I
would agree even though that stuff is is
also pretty familiar territory to tread
yeah I feel like they the acting is just
so much better and the writing better
better the writing is better the
production designs and the production
values coales much better on that
timeline because when we cut back to the
present especially when we were in the
desert throughout a lot of that uh I I
could really feel when we were switching
back in force between okay this is on
location but this is on a volume or some
kind of green screen and and they're in
these pristine what look like freshly
purchased costume clothes uh that are
like even after like avalanching down a
hill you know in the desert you know are
only vaguely kind of dusted up
afterwards they have these like pristine
designer sunglasses and and I don't know
yeah it like it's so weird it feels like
two different sets of writers are
writing these different
I guess which is like a fun experiment
but also yeah you get back to the
present and again this episode I was
like no I'm going to give the benefit of
the doubt I really liked May's
confession scene for instance um but
there is something just kind of
frustrating and a little Annoying about
the way that they're the most the
character I like the most on the present
day timeline is is uh the one they call
Madame wazelle or whatever she comes the
the the Monarch op who's you know uh you
know what's her name from the MCU John
no keep explaining because I clearly
don't know who you're talking about
she's she's my favorite on she's the
most actualized character to me on the
current timeline and maybe it's because
she's mysterious and she don't say much
but like I don't know she's got a lot of
presence and I believe her in ways where
the rest of them feel detached and even
Kurt Russell still while he had more to
do here I'm like I still feel like they
just kind of plopped you in and we're
just like hey man do your thing you know
yeah he was a little more intense this
time and the scene with her I thought
you know that exchange with the French
and her clearing out the van and him you
know like kind of sizing up the
situation with her I thought that was
good you know and uh and then we get
dude it's the three leads suck I got to
tell you man they are keep trying to
like are not good
characters hate to break it to everyone
but I was bad for those actors I was on
board for for that at first Kate I
thought was great the first episode um
but the more we spend time with these
characters the more I'm just like God
when you guys speak I check out like the
dialogue for I force myself to pay
attention the second you guys start
talking I'm like oh man just too much
damage has been done yes I don't even
know if I can warm up to you guys now I
I want them just start slice of lifing
them because I'm just like anything just
like don't give them something different
to say give them something completely
unrelated to talk about for like a hot
minute like I loved doing the the the
ball thing at the beginning cuz we're
doing Exposition but we're also like
fading in and out of like human moments
which just don't seem to exist at all on
the on the modern timeline looking for
my dad well I I I just think they they
make them all say the same it's just the
same line same lines and hammering the
same go kind of delivery every freaking
every time my God there's no range
always so posed and they're always so
pristine like let them be a little bit
like their actual
out ruffing it traversing the world now
in a desert after been like kataro just
seems so like lifeless they just all
seem like they're along for this whes
like they're the same twoo performances
throughout the entire show and may other
than the one time she's like lamenting
her like the whole thing she did is just
dry it it they're the they are the three
most boring leads you could put in your
show when you're like we're going to
make our human characters interesting
and they're always aggravated with each
other that
makes abrasive to watch they're so
boring but everything else is actually
intriguing other than I this this
episode only um made that Crystal to me
was we didn't really give them that much
dialogue we didn't really give them that
much time everyone else did and I was
like this is the best episode what was
was different other than you know
Focus oh we didn't really focus on them
yeah they only kind of hearkened back
when there was like a mirror in the
action to to get back to or something
and when we did focus on them they had
the same same [__] they say all the time
and when they were about to run off into
the desert at the very end and Kate is
like brimming you she's like she has
like some Spirit about her she's like
almost excited she's like no no we're
good come on was like oh maybe this will
be a splash of color and then we
immediately the moment was too predict
immediately had to reset that it felt
like such a scene like like like such a
okay play this H like it was so obvious
that okay well she's doing this now
because some information getting dealt
through away then we're right back to
the same tone we're used to with her
character guitar just being like so
aggravating May
Kate Godzilla and even their dad is
looking for Dad Dad is is even getting
on my nerves oh he's annoying too yeah
dude no they're all very annoying and
and and I I I think we've spent five
episodes trying to as much as we've
complained we've tried to deconstruct
like but what are they going for and I
want to see what yeah and but I got to
tell you man six episodes in they are I
should like something about any of these
people the best people on the modern
timeline remain Tim Madame wazelle and
the Annie McDow lady who like the least
focused on well they even get the guy
the I forget his name but the doctor
character and the past oh Suzuki great
great breath of fresh air excellent yeah
breath of fresh air uh again everyone in
the past intrig like the military people
feel more evil and menacing than you're
menacing Monarch characters and like
you're you're menacing military people
in the past feel more menacing than your
modern day modern characters it's so
weird cuz they're not writing
extraordinarily more complex stuff for
the past characters to deal with they're
just mixing them together in something
that feels more like actual life and the
visuals are are solid I I I think this
is the first time in the monster verse
could be wrong but I feel like it's
correct like we're so used to seeing
Godzilla and City Landscapes usually in
wet yeah it's
raining and uh that is wet sure
raining involved droplets maybe a wave
who knows wet Joe yeah water yeah
wet that's
wet but this is the first time I think
we've seen him in like just the driest
of Landscapes which I thought was cool
uh to see mhm just oh my God these
character I'm sorry I I try to move past
it but I can they're just so stupid like
it's so weird this the the only reason
they found their dad was following Shaw
was following Kurt Russell yeah and then
they see God like right face to face she
has this moment where she's like he
looked at me and he's like yeah gotta go
find my
dad my dad uh we're g to go for own like
where are you going to go where are you
going to go what are you going to do
alone what are you doing especially now
that she sold you out I mean you like
you you had to get to that point to find
it out but also they're still heading
you know 10 clicks that way to go back
before dinner so like what are you going
to yeah what do you expect to I don't
know maybe that'll open up a new passage
of the show where they can find some new
character that'll that'll enchant this
timeline but uh canaro is definitely the
worst of them though I I would if I were
to rank that canaro is the worst he's
every line they give him is like he says
it with the same delivery yes every
single time like there's there's there's
a difference between like subtle and
just no effort like being put in to give
him stuff I I don't I just can't handle
chilling they they undercut everything
Kate does by making her look like a
supermodel all the time instead of just
like trusting that she's beautiful and
letting her be in costume and then uh
ciry Clemens is is like in a drama is
trying to be in a drama yeah none of
them match what kind of thing they're
trying to be in and and it just doesn't
feel like the script cares I don't know
so weird it doesn't feel like the script
cares at all to give in that dance scene
we had that little interlude where they
have the the like the sound Fades out
and we're in an intimate moment and it's
just sensory and I'm like you could find
some weird way of doing that the closest
we've ever gotten on this modern
timeline is when they're singing in the
wreck Zone in the last episode which was
like fine that's nice you know but it
also seemed like a stupid moment for
yeah I know was shoehorned in there also
felt like what are you doing you guys
know there's a bunch of soldiers out
here yeah going to hunt down you
undercut by like carelessness of writing
or or you know it's or or the they could
have even play I don't know they could
have played that in a way where it's
like he's trying to keep quiet but he's
also trying to you know uh uh break down
her defenses and and you know warm her
up and and yeah I don't know it just
seems like I I don't I don't understand
how this happens because if they do have
two teams riding both timelines it feels
like there's no communication between
them and I feel like somebody in
assembling these episodes would have to
be like hey we should probably get on
the same page here I mean this was my I
still think this was probably their best
episode they've done because of all the
reasons we said because like the like
the things we have complained about the
most are barely the runtime of the
episode and all the highlights of the
episode are the majority of the runtime
so I totally like even like Bill Randa
in the past I think is a very fun
charismatic character love I think k is
a really compelling character as well
great presence um and good they all have
chemistry like like a like Asian female
scientist at at the at a time where it's
like wow that's those are not just Asian
Japanese female SCI at a time where like
being any of those as a scientist is not
like not not a popular thing like a very
intriguing character um with a lot of
depth to her and and then uh yeah Kurt
Russell scenes where he's not with the
main casted characters are
great and and yeah there was like some
actual moments of suspense and some cool
and some like mon both moments of
Godzilla both coming out of the water
and even the debate they have in the
past of of I thought I think that's such
an interesting debate like they think
they killed Godzilla they discover he's
alive and and what do we do now what do
we do and then tell the world
frustration of the conversation like I
love that that little transa that little
um yeah transaction of dialogue between
for like like maybe just a page is worth
of dialogue yeah of we we used America's
most deadly weapon against it and we
couldn't do it and then what are they
going to do then sh they're going to
build an even greater weapon and if that
doesn't work they'll build a greater one
if it's not working on them they're
going to test it on I was like damn that
is that's a really great Point like what
what do you do that is so much more
ining more like anything else that yeah
well and on top of that and then it
leads into like a a detriment for them
right away you know yeah absolutely and
that plays into the greater Stakes that
he talks about with Pucket about like
it's about the choice that you make and
if you make the right choice you can run
the organization the way that you see
fit and you know then he goes out for
love but then they find this discovery
this is a big deal like it all mashes
together in a way that actually feels
alive and compelling absolutely yeah so
um and now the bad guys are taking over
and we're going to going to see the soul
yeah I I like the also the portrayal the
fight for the soul of Monarch and
personifying that in these characters
Yeah man so there's a lot of there's a
lot of really good stuff in here yeah um
that is that you just can't help but get
frustrated when you're like okay Su is
the the problem is the [__] three
leads they got that they they're just
not written I I don't they're just not
they're not ritten well and and I'm like
I I can't even tell you if the actors
are good or not I know because I'm like
is it the actors I don't think so
because the freaking writing of them is
the same dialogue yeah and it doesn't I
don't know it's the one part of the show
where when I'm watching it the movie
Magic comes apart and I don't feel like
anyone's direct being directed by
anybody like the three leads and Kurt
Russell when he's with the leads don't
feel like anyone's directing them it
feels like it's just kind of up to them
to make a scene happen and I don't know
why I'm getting that impression but yeah
and then you know I'm starting to notice
like oh here are the effects and there
are the wardrobes and and yeah that's
these are just all the wrong problems to
have but hey that's where we're at
people um what did you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
um we you only got a couple more left
how many got six we got four left jeez
hey these leads could still improve they
can still give us a compelling emotional
thread there's still time to rewrite the
Sho there's still hey you can always
kill them all they have like she might
have a a psychic link with Godzilla that
that could be cool or I'm afraid
Godzilla is going to be like no I should
have crushed you I'm sorry yeah I don't
waste these Bonds on just anybody 30
seconds later she moves on yeah she's
just like got to get out of here like oh
my God what a great moment you have with
this character to like her trauma is so
rooted in in and like she's got a lot of
trauma but man she had the devastation
of everything that happened her she was
there on the grounds for gday she was
there and she comes face to face with
the monster
and and 30 seconds later it's just like
I'm going to go find my dad well we
don't even in that sequence bad that
sequence is it's the time where you
would absolutely want to throw in some
of those PTSD flourishes and
reallya yeah it's the time Jesus watched
it like oh God and it just plays like a
regular action scene and then she
gallivant off 10 clicks that way yeah so
weird oh my God and it just feels like
then the PTSD is just a device so that
in the Godzilla list episodes they can
be like well here's a justification for
why we can show
godzill
[__] God they really let me down here
man it's great I love the show it's
great uh I I still look forward to
watching still the still the best
episode still the best still the best
episode I still liked it lot of I still
like this one over like uh like
definitely like a landslide over to the
like side of Yes Man the the the parts
that don't work like oh did they cast a
shadow hey we got we got two episodes
100% in the present last couple then
hopefully next two will be 100% in the
past man we can do that for a while and
then tie it all around at the end all
right guys well leave your thoughts down
below pick a name John any name guo
Galindo John went with the first person
the one we don't know guo gindo guo
Galindo you are the first patron of the
day shout out that we are doing you know
what Santa's giving you this year for
Christmas the first shout out at the
real rejects of December 20123 Good
Golly and it's a Greg shout out why
because you kicked it off I mean I'm
here too but your name begins with G
gto's names begin with G there's so many
G's we're doing a classic here go to
chat G no what gole we can use our own
brains okay okay my brain's been
corrupted by this process I can't think
for myself any longer I need you and I
need G stands for good boy you stands
for under my sheets with me I stands for
I like to kick men in the balls and it
turns me on T stands for turned on by
you gito oh St for oh that hurts when
you kick me in the balls ooh are we
going full name or just sure why not
it's Christmas we'll see how this goes
St for go stop kicking me in the balls
hey STS for try the ass now L stands for
uh Licking which is what you're giving
me I stands for I like to eats pickles n
stands for nachos cuz everyone loves
nachos d stands for dang dog digity with
the
did oh stands for uh what you give each
and every one of us when we think of you
guo thank you so much for being part of
our patreon page you super sexy reject
you we love
[Music]
you